Gone are the days where thousands of people pack into a single space,...
...standing shoulder to shoulder and side by side.
Music festivals and concerts that draw large crowds...
...will probably be off-limits for awhile...
...and so event organizers around the world are coming up with different ways...
...for people to have a bit of fun.
Take this concert in the UK, for example.
Around 2,500 fans gathered at a park in Newcastle to watch a show by musician Sam Fender,...
...but instead of people standing altogether,...
...groups of five are separated on a metal platform at the arena.
Meanwhile, here at home, people are also experimenting with different solutions.
Fans in Toronto were treated to an outdoor concert Thursday night, drive-in style.
Music goers enjoyed The Reklaws from the comfort of their cars.
Another once in a lifetime experience, a new festival inspired by the pandemic.
It's called Krugo Fest.
The event allowed for people in Regina to book a private hotel room...
...and attend a music festival from their balcony.
We've put our stage on the rooftop of a parking structure...
...that's adjacent to the DoubleTree by Hilton in Regina.
The hotel has 108 rooms with balconies that overlook the rooftop stage that we've built.
Morrison says tickets start at 600 dollars...
...which includes a room, a meal and some concerts.
More than that, proceeds from each ticket will go to a local food bank.